We previewed earlier this week that this might
happen and it sort of has Donald Trump's former
national, one of his former national security
advisors, John Bolton, one of the most disgusting
neo-con Warhawks of the last 20 years has
been called to testify in the impeachment
inquiry of Donald Trump. Next week, if Bolton
shows up and we'll talk about that, Bolton
would be really the first major witness in
this entire thing, and Bolton, as I've said
before, is not a good guy.
He was one of the architects of the Iraq war.
He just loves a good old war for either regime
change and or oil. He's a total hothead, but
he believes in defending his values as he
sees them. Now, they're not my values. They're
probably not yours. But Bolton believes that
Trump's values are not the right ones. He
was not pleased with Rudy Giuliani smear seeking
projects under Trump. He called them Rudy's
drug deals, including looking for dirt on
political opponents, including Joe Biden.
If Bolton testifies it could be absolutely
explosive. We have every reason to think that
Bolton could do serious damage to Donald Trump
based on what he knows. The white house on
the one hand of course, is urging Bolton and
others just don't show up. No surprise. That's
been their approach all along. Now, let me
immediately give you what some are saying
is bad news, but I don't actually think it
is.
Last night a John Bolton's attorney, and of
course, if you worked for Trump, you probably
need a lawyer right about now. And Bolton
has one Bolton's lawyer says that without
a subpoena, John Bolton's not going to be
there. And, uh, we might imagine that this
is a suggestion that Bolton is not going to
show up. I don't believe that. That's the
case. It is not uncommon in these situations
that the potential witness will request a
subpoena or say I won't show up without one
because if they show up voluntarily and say
things that Trump or whoever take issue with
that is a very different scenario legally
for Bolton. Then if he was subpoenaed to testify.
So it is not uncommon that further own protection
from future potential reduction of liability
from something like a civil suit or perjury,
you know, whatever it is that Trump might
allege a, a John Bolton engages in.
It is not uncommon for Bolton to say for someone
in Bolton's position, rather to say, I will
only show up if I am subpoenaed. Um, here's
the bottom line. If we can get Bolton to this
committee, Bolton is a bloodthirsty and ruthless
neo-con whose political views I find absolutely
disgusting, but that doesn't matter. I would
not want Bolton as my public political enemy
and that indeed may be terrible for Donald
Trump. This could get ugly in the best way
very, very quickly. We live in extraordinarily
strange times. I acknowledge that where someone
is deprived in his political beliefs as John
Bolton might actually signal or be the catalyst
for the start of a a what is ultimately maybe
an attempt to write our democracy which has
been turned on its head by this administration.
That phrase about politics makes strange bedfellows
has become almost apocryphal at this point,
but it seems particularly accurate right now
and if Bolton's going to be the catalyst for
maybe starting to write the ship that is on
its way down, then that's a good thing and
we should anxiously and positively await the
testimony of John Bolton. I'll let you know
as soon as I know whether he has been subpoenaed
and whether he will indeed be there next week.
Let's take a quick break. Give us a like on
Facebook at facebook.com/david Pakman show.
After this, there is a tweet for everything
that is the uh, meme that best applies to
what we will discuss after this brief break